ja und wir kommen zu einer geschichte
die so skurril ist dass man es fast
nicht glauben kann und aber trotzdem so
passiert ist nämlich am münchner
flughafen eine 74 jährige armenierin
will mit ihrem koffer durch die
gepäckkontrolle die beamten
durchleuchten den koffer wie das eben so
ist
und finden etwas mit dem sie niemals im
leben gerechnet hätten was das weiß bild
reporter karl ich hab das jetzt schon
groß angekündigt und die spannung
aufgebaut erzählt uns was haben denn die
beamten im koffer gefunden
ja die beamten haben einen schädel und
mehrere knochen in diesem koffer
gefunden denn man muss ja so verstehen
wir kennen das ja vom flughafen wenn wir
da ein schicken wir geben unser gepäck
ab und dann wird es durch geleuchtet und
wenn es dazu auffälligkeiten kommt die
flüssigkeiten oder auch beispielsweise
sprengstoff dann die ganze
alarmierungskette dann losgetreten in
dem fall kam der bundespolizei
landespolizei und der zorn auf dem plan
gucken sie das an
um auszuschließen dass es keine
tierischen knochen sind aber eine ärztin
festgestellt es ist ein menschlicher
knochen und daraufhin wurden dann die
beiden personen ausfindig gemacht die in
dieser koffer gehört einer 74 gegen
armenien und ihrer tochter die auf der
durchreise waren über münchen über kiew
dann nach jerewan der hauptstadt von
aserbaidschan und waren dann auf der
durchreise und dann wurde das alles
durchleuchtet die beiden mussten dann
mit auf die wache kommen mussten dann
auf die wache kommen und wurden dort
befragt warum sie das im koffer dabei
haben und dann haben sie gesagt ja da
sind die überreste das sind die
skelettteile der meines verstorbenen
mannes der 2008 bereits verstorben ist
und die lebt die familie lebte in
griechenland und er sollte jetzt eine
letzte ruhe finden in armenien ich habe
vorhin als er mit armenien
und jetzt muss man natürlich fragen er
soll seine letzte wohl dort finden
konnte die frau dann weiterreisen
ja aber nur mit verspätung den durch die
kontrolle haben sie einen anschlussflug
verpasst denn es muss natürlich erst mal
geprüft wie einen liegt hier eine
straftat vor dazu habe ich gesprochen
mit dem opera staatsanwalt thomas
steinkraus koch von der zuständigen
staatsanwaltschaft landshut und der hat
uns gesagt nein das es handelt sich um
keine straftat die beiden frauen konnten
die papiere vorzeigen das ist konnten
griechische papiere vorlegen dass das
alles legal war und genehmigt war und
sie konnten auch ein papier vorlegen
dass das ausreichend desinfiziert war
von daher konnten diese frauen dann mit
verspätung zwar aber sie konnten
problemlos weiterreisen